here's everybody Deadpool's killed in
the Marvel Universe part three so after
killing the Incredible Hulk he kills
Jimmy madrak's Multiple Man by spraying
him down with a machine gun he kills a
Green Goblin off the panel by cutting
his head off and he kills power pack by
basically destroying their ship he
tortures Professor Xavier into summoning
the X-Men and then when Cyclops gets a
substance wrapped around his head he
tries to blow it off with his own optic
blast and when he does that it basically
explodes which kills Emma Frost and
pixie alongside Cyclops Colossus Rogan
Gambit are stuck in a room where the
walls are closing in and when it looks
like Colossus can keep them safe
Deadpool electrocutes them all to death
Xavier dies after reading Deadpool's
mind and realizing that they're all
fictional comfortable characters and
Xavier's brain shuts down from the shock
magnetos killed while trapped in acidic
jelly Kitty pride is stuck running
through a mirror maze forever
Wolverine's kids are tortured to death
Beast is killed off panel and Deadpool
wears his skin as a pelt and then
Deadpool decapitates Wolverine using a
carbonadium sword after killing doctor
strange and Wong make sure you guys
follow for part four